[Musique]
on l'attend
herat dans l'ouest de l'afghanistan
il y a dix mois cette lycéenne était
plongé dans ses livres d'école elle
passe désormais ses journées pencher sur
cette machine à coudre car depuis qu'ils
ont pris le pouvoir les talibans
interdit sophie de plus de 11 ans
d'aller à l'école
cette partie devrait être plus large ok
à partir d'ici en ligne cette partie est
bien comme ça c'est ça bravo ma fille
depuis que les écoles sont fermées je me
suis tourné vers la couture ça m'occupe
et ça me permet d'évacuer le stress que
je ressens c'est tellement difficile
chaque nuit j'imagine qu'au réveil le
matin je vais à l'école mais cela
n'arrive jamais tout est déprimant
pour des raisons de sécurité ses deux
soeurs lycéenne préfère garder
l'anonymat comme des millions d'afghanes
elles ont cru aux promesses des talibans
qui s'étaient engagés à les laisser
réétudier des promesses qui n'ont
toujours pas été tenues à ce jour
les talibans veulent seulement que les
femmes restent à la maison et fasse des
enfants mais nous devons garder nos
rêves et nos espoirs je veux continuer
mes études et devenir un jour un bon
médecin pour servir ma communauté
dans cette école privée du centre des
rates seules les classes d'élémentaire
sont ouvertes les garçons et les filles
apprennent ensemble ouvrez votre livre à
quelle page est vous
qui peut me dire ce que ces
scientifiques ont inventé weir a déjà
bien ma douce enfant peux tu me le dire
c'est thomas l essonne il a inventé
l'électricité bravo oui c'est correct
nadia lalami tentent chaque jour de
faire bonne figure devant ses élèves
mais lorsqu'elle pense aux jeunes filles
banni de l'établissement elle peine à
retenir ses larmes
[Musique]
j'espère que dieu nous ouvrira les
portes
je souhaite qu'un jour
avec l'aide de dieu
les écoles rouvrent pour les filles plus
âgées c'est mon souhait et marquette à
l'émirat islamique qu'il pense aux
filles plus âgées
j'aimerais connaître plein de choses
comme mon institutrice
quand nous aurons terminé notre année de
sixième nous ne pourrons plus continuer
l'école j'espère que les talibans nous
autoriserons un poursuivre nos études
on est triste pour nos soeurs et leurs
amis qu'ils ne peuvent plus aller à
l'école pour continuer leurs études et
qui ne peuvent pas réaliser leurs rêves
au coeur de la ville dans la plus grande
discrétion
certaines ont décidé de combattre
l'injustice faite aux jeunes afghanes
cette enseignante par exemple donne des
cours à une cinquantaine de collégiennes
et deux lycéennes dans l'arrière cour de
sa maison
elles étaient mes élèves à l'école
publique elle par exemple elle aussi les
autres n'étaient pas à l'école où
j'enseignais
j'ai peur mais j'accepte de risquer ma
vie en donnant ses cours en cachette car
quand un homme étudie ces pour lui-même
mais quand une femme étudie la société
tout entière en bénéficient
car ce sont les femmes qui élèvent les
enfants qui feront la société de demain
pourquoi les hommes peuvent-ils étudier
et pas nous comment l'éducation des
femmes peut-elle être un péché
dans des quartiers de la ville des pères
de famille se mobilise pour convaincre
les talibans de laisser leur fils y
étudier il en appelle aux mollahs comme
dans cette mosquée
nous souhaiterions que vous alliez voir
le gouverneur pour qu'ils rencontrent
les autorités de l'émirat islamique afin
de plaider en faveur de la réouverture
des écoles pour les filles pour qu'un
pays fonctionne il a besoin de la
contribution des femmes et des hommes
le gouvernement devrait donc autorisé
l'éducation des filles
d'accord je vous assure que j'irai
demandé au gouvernement d'ouvrir les
classes aux filles en respectant la
charia islamique
en tant que spécialiste de l'islam je
pense que si l'éducation est un besoin
pour les hommes il est aussi pour les
femmes mais dans un cadre islamique
hommes et femmes ne doivent pas être
ensemble dans la classe seules les
femmes doivent enseigner aux étudiantes
je suis en faveur de l'ouverture des
écoles pour les filles mais seulement
dans ce cadre islam est requis un avis
partagé par certains hauts responsables
talibans à l'exception de la branche
dure du mouvement fondamentaliste et
c'est elle qui à ce jour a le dernier
mot